you could do a ton you could do a ton in
60 second Tick Tock videos it's called
you can Peak Interest for them to click
the URL in your profile to listen to The
One Hour podcast almost all my social
content is just a gateway to the longer
form content and vice versa they work
together so to me the 60 second content
is the marketing you know it is the
setting up to the longer form you know I
think a lot of people who have serious
content have overly disrespected social
because they understood that they
couldn't fit it all into that package
you know no business can fit all of its
information into any marketing the
marketing is there for you to go deeper
with their lack of friction in the
internet world it's there for you I
liked it I like the point you made about
school doesn't teach what the students
need to know that's the whole premise of
the class I teach at Stanford is like
here's the real stuff you need to know
correct but you can only swoop in and do
how many physical classes yeah exactly
correct and like the windows small
whereas when you make me media for the
modern web you can go deeper
you can you can create very narrow
conversations with a guest or guests it
really matters
so how about so one of the guests I have
that's common recurring is like someone
who's 26 and they just took over running
a business that's the most common sort
of people we employ we have hundreds of
those people at Alpine
um we probably have 150 like 20 to late
20s early 30 year olds somethings that
run companies is that an audience like
do you think there's a big enough
audience the people who want to hear
that yeah and I think you know kind of
like you know I'm in a very good mood
today because my Jets pulled off a
miracle so when I think about the NFL
you think about the two conferences when
I hear you say that I'm like yeah and
there's two groups of people there's the
people that want to go into private
equity and be in a place where they
eventually are part of a firm that they
maybe have to jump in and run it for a
little while jump out and then you have
a enormous uh audience of family
business operators right who are either
kind of old school driven like I am
which was you're I was operating a
family business that I knew from day one
was a family business forever then you
have a different subgroup of family
business operators who are coming in to
run their family business and the
parents have said and they've said to
themselves I'm going to operate this for
exit within the next 10 years that's
already another subgroup with and it's
almost like a division within a
conference using the football analogy so
I think yes comma there's some
significantly interesting subgroups
within that group 25 year olds to 35
year olds to run a business is like one
of the biggest groups in the world right
now most people out there think of it
actually as VC Mark Zuckerberg right
like kids that raise capital I would
argue that that's the smallest sector
the far bigger sector is family business
takeover and then you have another small
sector similar to VC backed which I
think is private Equity DNA where the
person goes into it knowing that they
want a couple of chapters maybe one two
or three bites at the Apple of being
operators
um at some point in their lives and then
that content over indexes for former
operators in their 50s and 60s
who've joined private Equity with a 50
thinking that I might have to do one
more at-bat and go take over and run
something when the operator can't do it
after we make the investment and those
themes for that 60 year old may not be
the same for that 27 year old but
there's probably a 50 crossover of
content which creates audience and
interest in the subject matter yeah I
love that like for example it's back to
playing chess or counter punching or
mixed martial arts it's really chess I
was creating content I didn't know that
I was going to go down parenting themes
it was a reaction to who was resonating
with my content which was parents trying
to understand why their kids were
resonating with my content initially
thinking they didn't like me because of
the cursing or the energy and then
finding themselves overvaluing me I mean
my inbox now has in the last seven years
has gone from parents being mad at me
and saying stop cursing stop telling my
kid not to go to college to in the last
24 months you're the only person my kids
listening to you're you're actually
pushing the agenda I want them to please
keep doing it don't ever stop nice and I
think for every content well your
content's changed a little bit well at
all but it changed because I was
listening to the emails I was like wait
a minute you know and some of it was
doubling down when the parents were
pushing I'm like you're pushing for the
wrong thing
it's very real and you'll feel this as
you start to grow
direct message number one hey Gary like
you're a real Menace like stop doing
this you're like telling my kid not to
go to college who the [ __ ] do you think
you are next DM hey Gary my I'm in deep
depression I'm now on a lot of
medication and starting to use alcohol
and drugs because my parents are making
me go to Yale and I want to be an artist
you start reading that over and over and
over again you become more invigorated
to say [ __ ] you you want to help these
kids because then what and by the way I
just painted you two I didn't paint you
the full diamond then the ninth message
is Gary I have a problem my kid is in
big trouble they hate me
and I think some of the stuff you're
talking about might be why I over pushed
them to be an engineer now they won't
speak to me
like what do I do so all of a sudden
you're sitting in this place where you
know you have Gift of Gab or
communication skills and by the way I
felt this
10 years ago when my audience was so
small nobody knew who the [ __ ] I was it
doesn't take much to feel compelled when
you're reading this stuff yeah yeah yeah
let me switch to that please
um so the other the other area that I
have a ton of energy for is just like
personal growth yes so like if I like my
really short story is I grew up in a
blue collar Town yes single mother yes
and uh I started listening to these
audio tapes yeah like uh Tony Robbins
yeah of course Brian Tracy has Moen
Lawns and it like made you believe doing
the stuff they said and it worked like
it actually like little by little
started hitting all these goals yes and
I feel like I feel like that content is
kind of missing or it's getting lost in
the noise like on the platforms at least
that I'm on so I have a lot of energy to
bring some of that content because it
was hugely life-changing for me so I'm
thinking like
I I haven't been I mean I don't know how
much you can do in 60 second Tick Tock
videos well what you can do it you could
do a ton you could do a ton in 60 second
Tick Tock videos it's called you can
Peak Interest for them to click the URL
in your profile to listen to The One
Hour podcast almost all my social
content is just a gateway to the longer
form content and vice versa they work
together so to me the 60 second content
is the marketing
it is the amuse-bouche you know it is
the setting up to the longer Forum all
you know I think a lot of people who
have serious content have overly
disrespected social because they
understood that they couldn't fit it all
into that package well you know no
business can fit all of its information
into any marketing
the marketing is there for you to go
deeper with the lack of friction in the
internet world it's there for you and
you think the long form is a podcast
I think the long form is a very personal
self-awareness framework of how one
communicates best
Malcolm Gladwell communicates better in
the written word than he does in audio
and video
for me I'm incapable of communicating in
the written word my employees know when
I send a company-wine email they're like
rco can't spell like why are we here you
know and so
um you know and so and so I think um
look for me it is very clear that video
is the most powerful medium
and that's been proven but Howard Stern
did just fine on radio and Rush Limbaugh
and many others built their brand in
that of sports radio Mike in a Mad Dog
and then there's the written word and
Harry Potter is profound and Malcolm
gladwell's profound and Michael Lewis
and so I think that's a game of one's
capability and then I always tell people
also focus on what you like to do you
might be a better writer but you
actually enjoy making videos you're
probably better off doing well the
answer is always both but you're better
off probably end of the day if you can
only pick one to do video because if you
like it you'll do it
and then how do you like you've got a
number I I'm in a similar situation with
you I have a lot of interests that are
actually like not scattered yeah like
I'm building a private Equity Firm yep
I'm teaching uh a class which takes a
tremendous amount of time and then how
do how do you think about
those priorities versus like the content
that you're creating and I know I
believe every human being has an hour
that they don't think they have
so is that really what you it takes an
hour you think
yeah it all depends on the info you know
luckily given that you're in the private
Equity business you may have the
resources to you know for a lot of
people watching they may not have the
financial resources to make it an hour
when I used to do all the editing and
not like you know it didn't take that by
the way all my editing was record stop
post I became an improv no editing no
lighting no audio maker with Wine
Library TV because I didn't have the
capabilities or the money to hire
someone to do it I did that for seven
years people forget that part they only
see the end they don't see that Journey
which is so for you yeah it could only
which is why it's so great to host a
show
because you're in the business of
getting the content and bouncing off of
it out of the person that's with you so
become it's not like teaching a class
where there's prep
what do you mean by that what I mean by
that is you if you're interviewing a
private Equity executive or schooling
executive or some other interests you
have surfing wine baseball whatever it
is you're just inner you know Scott
Boris shows up and you're like Scott how
did you start your career if as long as
you have the capability to react to the
words that they're answering you have a
very meaningful podcast right obviously
they're I'm very off the charts improv
clearly which is why a lot of them have
top 100 podcasts there are people who do
real prep work to ask the best question
when I did how you built this I was like
Jesus Christ he knows more about me than
I know about so clearly there are
different versions but in the spirit of
being busy if you're able to get
interesting people and you feel
comfortable in having conversations and
I already know that about you in the
limited interactions we have I think
your structure to not have to put in a
lot of prep time just the seven to ten
Asic questions if you're able to bounce
off of what they say should lead to a
very interesting podcast
and then in terms of just like building
in in from your perspective I mean is
your goal your podcast the podcast
itself is it the content you get from
the podcast that you're pushing out is a
little bit of both
and what
um in terms of the podcast itself
have you thought about just growing that
itself well I mean I think when you know
to me the circle works together right
now we're in such a great era for
creators because we're living through
the tick tockification of all social
media AKA for a decade you had to build
a lot of followers to get anything seen
now your first piece of content be seen
by a million people that's profound
so now we're a whole different world
where if you do a podcast the clips get
post on Tick Tock and and YouTube shorts
and Instagram reels which I think is
going to start following for a bigger
virality kind of Gap when I'm meeting
Gap is instead of all your reels getting
somewhat the same amount of views now
you'll start seeing some things go viral
but this the views you're getting are
declining because they have to have
those views for the virality
if in that copy your entire Instagram
reels profile is listen to the podcast
and the podcast is the default URL and
in the post-production of that reels
there's a logo saying listen to the
podcast you're using the content that
you got from the podcast to drive to
subscriptions for the podcast and it
becomes a viral Loop all right here's a
question I'll let you probably not when
you get asked out so let's say let's say
you had some actual marketing dollars to
put behind this
would you where'd you put where would
you put them I would
place where the person wants the
audience so for you there's very two
clear things on what I know so far the
debate would be do you run Tick Tock ads
because they're very underpriced yeah
for General awareness or do you run
LinkedIn ads for very targeted business
purposes and the answer is probably both
[Music]
and so you do at what about like I don't
know if people do this but about like
pay X dollars to get someone crazy on my
podcast you know I I mean I'm sure
people I'm sure people do it I haven't
really looked under the hood I'll say
something really funny you would be
flabbergasted
how many people say yes to the most
random podcast I have no listeners
and you have actually something to bring
to the table because when they Google
you they're like whoa and if you think
about a celebrity a person you know the
finance the private like these are you
know most of the people that have become
successful didn't get there by accident
right so Orion Reynolds act team
actually seeing that email from me like
be on this podcast
to me is like you'd be surprised how
much that might be in play Given that
you know the Gin he's just so
entrepreneurial he just might think it's
a good use of his time yeah
as long as you have the humility to deal
with a lot of no's and even just hearing
mowing lawn and blue collar that tends
to tell me that you probably do then
you're cruising in a game of just asking
35 people and then it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy you reach out
to the 55 people that you most want none
of them reply you do it one more time
one of them replies now they become the
name that you email the next 54 back and
be like look we had Malcolm Gladwell on
the show you know what I mean and so
I you know you know I I feel paying a
guest
is probably something that's going on a
lot something I'm completely unaware to
giving any advice on because I don't
know
but it's probably a worth a debate comma
I just have a funny feeling if you're
talking business World a lot of people
say yes even the biggest CEOs in the
world pop culture Fame world because of
what you do for a living I still think
you get five percent return on reach out
and that will be enough to get the
flywheel going
love it I love it all right what about I
don't know how I'm I'm going but it's 10
30. I think this is it but let's leave
this one last one last one okay so
um
what about some kind of like if that
took
I've combined a number of these
different topics and said okay I got a
lot out of this content I listened to
when I was mowing lawns I'm a professor
and I built like some kind of course
these have never seen it in like I mean
those I don't even sell it but just like
if you don't need to sell it I don't
need a Zone then I'm really into it
because I think if you sell it I don't
need it no anything yeah I know you
don't need to if that makes you like if
that's something that you think you know
for me because I'm so
um
I'm not you know it's funny I believe in
education more than anything structured
education feels so foreign to me it's
all osmosis and so but every time we do
anything on team Gary that's even
remotely structured like a deck or
something it crushes so I'm always like
have these like I laugh with myself I'm
like I really gotta force myself even my
last book I tried to make a like
workbook and like a textbook yeah yeah
and I just couldn't get there because
but for you it sounds like it's gonna be
easy to do that and I think that would
go quite well
um and then on that like
you know the the thing this is the last
thing yeah no worries well one of the
things I struggle with is like I I think
some of the some of the stuff you you
say and someone listens to there's an
impact but then there's also a part
where they need to do stuff well that's
right actually take the action and
that's
that's what I'm trying to I think now
you're talking about why I produce more
content than almost anybody on Earth I
believe the way someone takes action
is I do actually think there's a whole
group that is so literal that if you say
go take the course that works for them
for me it's the constant barrage of it
just hearing it over and over I fully
believe that yeah yeah I fully believe
that yeah when I wanted to get more into
physical shape in my late 30s I just
consumed a lot of that information most
of all was me forcing myself talking to
me about the guaranteedness of me living
20 years less and I just pounded into my
skull on every flight for six months and
then I finally did it I think most
people really do after constant barrage
of information
which is why I say the same [ __ ] over
and over and over in a hundred thousand
different ways in a hundred different
platforms all right this really is the
last question is there any risk of going
like off brand like no if I start off
brand is a is a
structure that is taught in marketing
schools that have nothing to do with
real life okay
what in theories off brand as a matter
of fact off-brand is when people most
start to enjoy things okay when Martha
Stewart went off brand and hung out with
Snoop she became more interesting not
less
off-brand is only bad if what you're
doing is upsetting people okay but if
you start talking a ton about serp I
keep I don't know what Fitness Fitness
that's going to be an additive okay you
know I mean you're talking to person
who's most done that right this post
might be about literally about something
very narrow business and next one might
be me screaming my head off because the
Jets won and I'm not worried about that
that's that's part of the equation I got
it I actually think it's a strength I
love doing a special I'm sorry no I just
said I love you you got a post on that
where you said that when you first go
off brand people are like what the hell
do you know about this I remember stay
in your lane wise this was huge for me I
mean I was so deep in wine world I
started talking about business
everyone's like stay in your lane wine
boy and I was like I was like I'm a
businessman before I was wine boy to you
you know like I you know I the lane is
your truth
yeah I like that you know thanks so much
you're welcome tonight
[Music]